very very strange story about President
Trump today I don't know if you're
hearing about this latest one but some
sources are saying that President Trump
has been complaining that he can't watch
porn at the White House yeah yeah
complaining about yeah when he heard
this Bill Clinton said wow thank God
Hilary lost man dodged a bullet man
[Music]
present Trump is busy though today
President Trump met with Shinzo Abe a
the Prime Minister of Japan yeah yeah
Trump took a hard line and said he'd
only lift trade tariffs if a BAE could
introduce him to Godzilla that was his
only request yeah that was really stupid
do you think he complained to Ave about
not not being able to watch porn what's
that yeah he complained it he probably
would he would bring it up to other can
you kid you what's going on yeah in your
prowess can you watch porn what happened
selfie on White House you got porn at
Starbucks just announced it will be
raising its coffee prices yeah yeah when
asked why Starbucks said cuz it's been a
week since we had any bad publicity we
had to do something okay can't go a
whole week delivery drivers for UPS are
reportedly planning to go on strike yeah
they're demanding higher wages shorter
hours and long pants they want long pad
they wore long pants they said the
technical term is big-boy pants I agree
with them give them some I always feel
bad you know I you know I like looking
at their legs I'll get to that later
NASA announced that the planet Mars
contains the building blocks for life
that is shoes yeah apparently Mars has
oxygen hydrogen and Netflix so we're
gonna be Netflix and chill I still don't
know what that means
you